Bioplastik teuer also super elastische reifen so heißt die neue
unvorstellbare erfindung der nasa eigentlich ging es nur um einen neuen reifen für einen zukünftigen mars-rover
Der ergebnis ist aber tatsächlich eine super alternative
Zum luftreifen für autos lkw flugzeuge und so weiter für uns alle
die
massenhaft vorteile mit sich bringt welche genau und in welchen bereichen das neue rad
Auch hier auf der erde schon bald eingesetzt werden können sie jetzt in klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Ein forschungsteam von glenn research center das der nasa angehört hat jetzt tatsächlich eine
Redewendung wahr werden lassen ihre erfindung ein rad aus einem
Drahtgeflecht das im ersten moment vielleicht an die ketten rüstung aus dem mittelalter erinnert und das hält extreme belastung
Aus also genau richtig für den einsatz im weltraum
Denn das thema dort ist schwierig und das wissen auch die ingenieure und ingenieurinnen die die entsprechenden fahrzeuge immer weiter
optimieren wollen doch dieser schritt ist wirklich sagenhaft denn der super lästig da ist zum einen fast
unvorstellbar pannensicher verantwortlich dafür ist die neuartige
verwendung von sogenannten form gedächtnis legierungen vielleicht hat er das mal in eurem
chemieunterricht mitbekommen form gedächtnis regierungen können unter gewissen umständen
Nach einer verformung wieder ihre ursprüngliche
gestalt annehmen und das birgt enormes potenzial das beispielsweise schon seit längerer zeit in der medizintechnik genutzt wird
werden durch stance also kleine röhrchen
Stabilisiert diese und weitere vorteile hat sich jetzt auch die nase zugemacht der super lässig teil besteht, im detail aus einem
nachgiebigen reifen der nicht
Genetisch ist also nicht luft gefüllt nicht aufgepumpt wird tragenden komponente stellt ein geflecht aus einer nickel titan legierung
Dadurch wird er tatsächlich super elastisch er kann damit eine dehnung von bis zu 10
unbeschadet überstehen zum vergleich elastische materialien wie feder stelle halten den um in der größenordnung von maximal
0,5 prozent aus bevor sie nach. Gehen dadurch bedingt wären bei off road bedingungen tatsächlich auch erhöhte
fahrgeschwindigkeiten weil es für diese reifen ja quasi keinen widerstand gibt möglich und
sie können sich an fast alles anpassen das heißt ein feldweg wird quasi zur autobahn zitat diese technologie kommt selbst mit hohen belastungen und
Übermäßigen verformen klar das schreibt die nasa auf ihrer webseite und es gibt noch weitere vorteile die
Tragfähigkeit der reifen wird erhöht und es wird kein innerer rahmen gebraucht das heißt die reifen beziehungsweise rat anordnung ist also in ihrem aufbau
sehr vereinfacht zudem sei auch die traktion
Also, die kraftübertragung des reifen auf die straße den
här könig luftreifen gleichzusetzen oder sogar überlegen die nasa bewerb den super lässig teuer mit den folgenden begriffen
Sicher stark robust einfach vielseitig und leicht und ihr könnt es euch denken anwendungen für diese erfindung gibt es massenhaft
gelände militär bau fahrzeuge könnten davon profitieren
Die nasa denkt aber auch schon eine einsatz bei flugzeugen und eben
Herkömmlichen autos nach und wenn ihr kein video zum thema und auch zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollen die ich in zukunft darüber machen werde
Dann, drückt mehr hier ein abo aufs auge und vergessen nicht den
Genau auf die knochen nur dann verpasst er kein video hier geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken mit tempo 200
unterirdisch durch die stadt sehr spannendes video ansonsten bis dann
flattern